The method that we're looking for, for
distance based phylogeny construction,
is called the "Neighbor-Joining Algorithm",
which was introduced in 1987.
It's a result so
fundamental to bioinformatics, in fact,
that it has been cited 30,000 times, and
it's one of the top 20 most cited
papers over all scientific fields.
So first, to see how this works,
define the neighbor-joining matrix
of a given distance matrix, D,
as the matrix D*, whose (i,j)-th entry is
given by the formula shown on the slide.
So, let me give you an example.
Here's the matrix that
we encountered before,
where j and k corresponded to the minimum
element of the matrix, but j and
k were not neighbors in
the tree that fit this matrix.
The total distance of a leaf node is just
the sum of distances from this leaf to
all other leaves.
So for example,
the total distance of k in this matrix is
21 plus 12 plus 13, or 46.
We will then define D*(i,j)
by taking n minus 2 times D(i,j) and
then subtracting the total distance of i,
and subtracting the total distance of j.
In this case, n, the number of leaves or
the number of rows in our
distance matrix, is equal to 4.
So D*(k,l)is equal
to 2 times D(k,l),
which is 13, minus 46, minus 48,
which gives us a value of negative 68 for
D*(k,l).
Now, if it's obvious to you that
defining this crazy matrix D* was
going to be a productive endeavor, then
you are probably far smarter than I am.
Like the Burrows-Wheeler transform,
which we encounter in another chapter,
which makes matching multiple patterns
to a text a lightning-fast endeavor,
I think this matrix D* is black magic.
Whereas taking a minimum element
of the original distance matrix
did not guarantee that we
were going to find neighbors,
taking a minimum element of
the neighbor-joining matrix, D*,
does find a pair of neighbors.
You can find a proof of this
theorem in a detour in the text.
It's not a short proof.
In fact, although
D* was introduced in 1987,
it took a decade before a proof
of this theorem was found.
Also, the Neighbor-Joining Theorem is
part of the reason why I led you down
the wrong path in the first
place when we first attempted to
construct a phylogeny
from a distance matrix.
Now, if we use D* instead of D,
then we will be able to successfully
identify a pair of neighbors from
a minimum element of the matrix.
So let's walk through
the neighbor-joining algorithm.
First, we construct the matrix D*, and
I'll move that up from the previous slide.
So there are two pairs of leaves that
correspond to a minimum element of D*.
i and j must be neighbors, and k and
l must be neighbors, as well.
Let's work with say, i and j.
We set delta(i,j)
equal to the total distance of i
minus the total distance of j,
all divided by n - 2.
So here when we plug those values in,
we see that delta(i,j)
is going to be equal to 9.
Now, you may remember before that we
had a formula for the LimbLength(i).
The formula that neighbor-joining uses
is going to give the same result when
the underlying distance
matrix D is additive.
But this formula offers better results
when we deal with non-additive distance
matrices, so that's why this formula
differs from the one that we had before.
Here, LimbLength(i) is equal to one half
of the original distance matrix value D(i,j)
plus delta(i,j),
and LimbLength(j) is equal to (1/2)
D(i,j) - delta(i,j).
So now that we have these limb lengths,
we can remove the i-th row and
the j-th row, as well as the i-th
column and the j-th column from D, and
then add a row that corresponds to
the parent node of i and j, or m, and
then we denote this smaller
matrix as D'.
For each other leaf k, we then
compute the distance between k and
this parent node, m, as the distance
from i to k, plus the distance
from j to k, minus the distance
from i to j, all divided by 2.
Does this formula look familiar?
I hope so.
It's the same formula that we
derived several sections ago,
when we first attempted to reconstruct
a tree from an additive matrix.
So, if we return to neighbor-joining,
now that we have a smaller matrix,
we can apply the neighbor-joining
algorithm recursively to D' and
obtain the tree on the right
that fits this matrix D'.
Once we have this tree,
we can simply re-attach the limbs of i and
j using the limb lengths that
we previously computed.
So here's the summary of
the neighbor-joining algorithm,
which we apply recursively until we
obtain a 2 x 2 distance matrix when
we form an edge, and then we retrace
our steps by adding limbs successively.
Go ahead, try implementing it yourself.
In particular, see what happens when
the neighbor-joining algorithm
is given a non-additive matrix,
because we know what's going to happen
when it's given an additive matrix.
The tree constructed by UPGMA on the same
non-additive matrix is shown on the right.
How does the tree that
you create by running
the neighbor-joining algorithm
differ from this UPGMA tree?
Of course, we can also apply
neighbor-joining to the non-additive
distance matrix that we
derive from coronaviruses.
But we can also apply it
to a distance matrix that
we obtain from pairwise alignment
of Spike proteins
taken from different patients, as well
as from the palm civet coronavirus.
When we do this, just from this
small sample of ten coronaviruses,
we can see a very clear pattern of how
the disease was passed from the palm civet
to residents in Southern China at the end
of 2002 and then how it spread to
other other residents throughout
the beginning of early 2003.
And then we see the cases from
the Metropol Hotel grouping together as
the disease went global.
It probably seems like we've come
a long way in our discussion
of distance-based approaches for
constructing evolutionary trees.
But we should point out that these
algorithms don't allow us to infer
anything about the ancestors
that are assigned to
the internal nodes of the tree.
The reason why we can't infer
anything is because when we passed
from a multiple alignment
to a distance matrix,
we inherently lost information
about the sequences themselves.
In order to say anything
about ancestral states,
we're going to need an approach that
can analyze the alignment directly.